welcome to this video playing get
another five-minute game and let's see
what happens here Poland is motor home
from the US guys playing d5 so I grabbed
the center bit of a weird opening for
black it seems rather passive okay you
might get in 97 85 going to and held in
an Alton an old Indian and old Indian
temple down I know it's not yeah let's
let's overprotect deform this makes
sense I guess so that a 5d five feet
does not have an ID for trying to play
quickly here
d 5 t 594 I can I can do h3 and maybe
even g form using the fact that I have
not cancelled you know 95 I guess norm h
3 yeah I'm going to play a damn maybe
maybe not immediately g4i depends what
he's doing if it takes on air three
Queen takes Knight goes back out doji
form no doubt but if you just retreats
the night yeah if it goes to at 6i might
take on default play 92 I don't think he
will get enough compensation for the
default poem yeah here okay I can also
go to be five this somewhat better and
some respect yeah I don't know what d 4
as a tact and he has no way to protect
it c 5 i'll take take deform and
sometimes blood gets compensation for
this kind of porn but it's normally
connected with the bishop on g7 which is
not the case here the question is one
question is Bishop Bishop somewhere to
see three or night be three you both
looking okay he may evil play d5 next
opening up the position yeah maybe maybe
here some the better tribe on d5 I could
consider yeah I could consider EDC dc5
returning one part for the pawn bishop
having two bishops in an open position
okay but let's let's see what he's doing
I pretty much expect him to play a d5
here only other move that makes some
sense maybe a 585 a form he needs to be
a yeah this businesses they only move
from making some sense opening it up
quickly okay let's grab him and after CD
and yeah I could go see 5 it's not a
terribly bad move they're getting born
one porn back for a very nice position
now go Bishop e3 years got this check on
before I don't don't really want that I
could also just castle can take on c4
whoop dee aid
there's also Queenie six in this
position for instance after Bishop a
five or something like that he's got 26
yeah okay this shouldn't be too bad
takes Bishop takes rook to e8 the only
thing i'm considering at the moment and
then I probably just play the Queen
somewhere to eat too may be attacking e7
and okay let's let's see where this
queen is going to go does not have any
great square on d6 he'll help is get it
by C five on c6 is getting hit by c5c
half may be deformed yeah that's also 94
Quincy 694 there's also not bad yeah he
doesn't have a good square Queenie 6
this rookie one also and diamond I'm
ahead on the clock for once trying to
play a bit quicker okay yeah I basically
only need to make sure that I'm not
blundering stuff if I'm not if I can
avoid that it should be really good
really nice this position
the ideas while the Queen trade is very
nice for me obviously and I was thinking
about c6c 6 is going to play rook c8
though does not let's check CC six loops
e8 I don't have a queen psycho or
something like that ok let's let's play
a good strengthening move the bishop
does not have a good square
mmm
I think really isn't this a win yeah
this is a win he needs to play rook a c8
and I just give the Queen that's rook c8
at the end he's got no way to prevent
that I've got rook c8 so I'm going was
it was what I'm trying to say
maybe III is something like that gaining
a temper form for Four Queens Queen um
twin maneuver somewhere other than that
I just play rook c8 Bishop c7m promote
yeah this is actually overlooked not
good yeah but this time I'm the one hat
on the clock
okay what's winning here hook see one
young taking and then black like that's
gone time going this was a bit fishy the
Queen Queen sack at the end but he had
no way to defend this with little time
yeah maybe after a night out after 94 I
need to ascertain you have a better move
that then what I did maybe I was
actually completely winning my line cb7
okay yeah I i had the hundred that might
be winning but computers actually gives
me plus 6 which the Queen sack okay add
overlooked Bishop d7 to be honest but
it's it's simply so strong that it
didn't matter it's a bit lucky yeah in
in the opening I don't think he has
enough compensation for the pawn here
this is not enough sometimes you can set
upon like that with the bishop on g7 and
then the long diagonal is the
compensation at them here it's just a
pawn you can maybe argue that this is
better maybe this is better t5 we have
this is probably in better if you look
at something like that I'm very nicely
centralized yeah also very good position
you know in the game it was it was
really nice I think he should have taken
you should have played that one him
tried to fight it this open position
with the bishop coming to be seven it's
um it's not great but what can you do
yeah yet it's very nice very nice for
white well and here the Queen sec
actually worked of interesting alright
thanks for watching